how do you die man how do you die
because no because I like it you know
when I listen to your acting stuff and I
see you like have these you know like
you get these visions and like you know
and you talk about how like you know
it's them it's life as a movie and
there's this thing you know and you how
do you die man cuz it has to be
something neat yeah
you can't die in a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass way
like in a like in a hospital can you I
don't want to I think that like this
cookies and [ __ ] on the table or
something in this [ __ ] yeah
somebody's supposed to be there with you
and they got a call or in the [ __ ]
hallway yeah he died um I think that uh
I you either this is how you go you
either you you're in your bed mm-hmm at
home mm-hmm you just have a malfunction
and pass away if you can't get that
mm-hmm
there's no oh he's got he's got cancer
he got take him to a hospital for
[ __ ] to two months and he dies there
I'm not doing that [ __ ] yeah bro don't
do that now uh oh [ __ ] he's on his last
leg I don't ever want anybody saying
that [ __ ] about me right why cuz you
don't want that news to get out or you
know I just don't know I don't want
that's boring regular [ __ ] yeah I want I
think honestly a cool way to go hmm you
gotta do something I know but who knows
if I'll be big then you know I mean who
knows if I'll have my if I have my I
think it'd be cool to like if somebody
like if somebody poisoned me like that I
like really like if I broke their heart
and then they poisoned me like some real
like Korean [ __ ] yeah you know what I'm
saying or like no Japanese I guess it
would be Japanese I don't mean to be
racist but no it could be either one
there's a lot of Korean no Korean is a
lot a lot of Grenada revenge yeah yeah
yeah let most multi-factor ever been a
movie in made by Koreans or Japanese
that wasn't about revenge
yeah but uh a lot of poison meat - in
all their films there's a lot of food
poison so so yeah so like if I broke
somebody's heart and I probably you
already did the thing that fellow
whatever you are its you've already done
waiting that's buried you milling in the
distance you've done it you've done it
you've done the thing that ruins you
you're done if I ran for president it's
already over
yeah way yeah me too just cuz a couple
of texts have probably sent 100% now I
could see this maybe you're at a diner
right here in the mountains right your
truck breaks down right and you thought
yet you like and you have a dog in the
back you try can't even [ __ ] serve it
to your dog but it fits the vision right
so you walk out you walk up to this
diner right you get in you call you know
maybe michael anoche or somebody or
maybe even um you know Chris Pine or
somebody I know him yeah and you call
them and they're like yeah we'll come
help you yeah and you but in the
meantime you're gonna wait you can have
a sandwich right and they don't have
anything on the menu that you like you
know for walk go figure right but the
lady says that they can make you
something special she says we have a
special of the day and it happens to be
like your favorite food and like oh
that's wild
so you get it you're sitting there
eating right you take two bites and then
you realize you're poisoning you look in
the distance and the waitress or the
manager is an old flame something wrong
yep yeah that's a way to go and I'll
tell you what to you verse and you'd
worse I would 100% respect I'd be scared
of [ __ ] I would cry probably but I would
but to have that gentle conversation
where they sit down and they let you
know what happened and they're like
listen i poisoned you this is it there's
nothing you can do about it you broke my
heart
you know and and I loved you and you
really hurt me in in you know 2008 or
whatever it was
yeah and you've lived your whole life
you're 77 and I never got remarried I
never had another guy I always you
always a person on my mind and I have to
kill you before I die and that's what I
did and I'm sorry but I had to do that
for me
dude tears running down my face man and
I hate the rest of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
before I died too I mean at all give me
a minute you have this special [ __ ] give
it to me I'll ingest it and all that did
I feel like crying right now man yeah
and that's how I'm gonna go that's how I
want to go dude and no [ __ ] that's
how I wanna go and if I take those last
few bites and I feel the poison swore my
throat up and I look over at that my dog
not my dog whatever the [ __ ] I thought
is sitting in that truck and I'm waiting
for [ __ ]
you know either my opener or Chris Pine
to get there and they dad died before
that I die before that bro but I'm
looking at that dog and I'm wondering is
that dog - that dog not mine that's the
last [ __ ] thought I have and I'm
holding the girl's hand and she gets it
and it's like I'm so sorry honey
yeah man that's the thing that's real
that's the real way bro because that
would mean something at the last moment
you'd be having at least an effect even
if that effect is that you are letting
them have that mode even if it's yeah it
would be something real yeah yeah it's
like you're like this Neil Armstrong for
like real [ __ ] sometimes
man that's just emotional yeah I I yeah
I would go that way I would like to go
that way actually
what would you go into battle could see
you may be going well that's another way
with a sword but not with a gun no no no
no but I don't want to get like all cut
up yeah soft battle maybe like slap
battle he died he died getting slow out
a lot that's West Hollis for checking
out this clip and if you want to see
another clip then you can look at this
clip or this clip either one of these so
did you pick one or he's still just
watching me do this cuz it's alarming